on va également parler de Julien c'est
mon élève chouchou sachez le je l'ai
kiffé dès le début j'avais regardé la
première voilà un petit peu après en
replay pour voir un peu c'est tout de
suite lui il m'a il m'a tapé dans l'oeil
voilà je le kiffe il est darka il fait
les mêmes il fait des vannes de paix
tout ça j'adore donc voilà je suis assez
fan tu vois c'est fan voilà je vous dis
la vérité je l'adore voilà c'est on a
voilà j'ai l'impression qu'on se
comprend tous les deux on se parle par
un grand interposé je kiffe ce gars il a
été sauvé pour la deuxième fois samedi
regarde
pas peur et vous pourriez me barrer si
seulement vous saviez
combien de fois la fin du monde nous
affolés
[Musique]
dans cette enveloppe c'est donc Julien
Julien qui est sauvé par le public ce
soir
[Applaudissements]
deuxième fois consécutive
moi ce que j'aime c'est la tête des
profs quand Julien est sauvé
d'animateurs savent que je viens de
soirée
totale pour moi je vous dis ainsi Julien
sort de la Star Ac c'est rideau terminé
c'est 500 000 à 600000 de moins de
téléspectateurs je le dis franchement
voilà c'est c'est la star du programme
dans tous les programmes insta regarder
à part ici où il y en a pas mais c'est
vrai que voilà il y a toujours une star
et
pourtant il ne cesse de se faire
réprimander par les professeurs
d'ailleurs il y en a un qui a été
particulièrement il y en a une qui a été
particulièrement violente avec Julien
c'est leur ballon la professeure
d'expression scéniques à la violemment
embrouillé tellement que la séquence a
été jugée humiliante par beaucoup de
téléspectateurs TF1 a décidé de la
couper la séquence de la quotidienne on
regarde la séquence et Mathieu qui était
avec nous qui est aussi un artiste
reconnu Mathieu vous êtes tous vous
faites tous de la musique dans la salle
de musique c'est tout non mais vous êtes
une famille voilà et je sais que voilà
mais l'artiste voilà exactement une
famille d'artistes connaîtra jamais ici
pourquoi tu as été choqué aussi regardez
en fait le truc c'est que j'ai
l'impression que vous avez vraiment du
mal à comprendre que le public mette
vraiment beaucoup et à faire du public
oui parce que si tu respectais le public
tu le draguerais pas en caméra
et dis pas non de la tête et regarde-moi
quand je te parle c'est humain tu as été
mal le médecin est venu tu as été mal
oui d'accord qu'est-ce qu'on en a à
faire le public t'aime qu'est-ce qu'on
en a à faire
c'est à toi de voir
c'est super merci
lors voilà après elle fait le spectacle
quand même
il est 20h47 on est en direct et c'est
vrai que là ça c'est des séquences qui
font parler d'émission c'est des
séquences qui sont besoins c'est des
séquences qui font que les gens vont
dire bah tiens je vais regarder comment
ça va se passer la semaine prochaine et
comment ça va se passer sur la
quotidienne entre les deux c'est plutôt
malin la vérité c'est ça qu'on aime et
c'est ça qu'on veut on crée des
personnages sinon on s'en tape qui a été
éliminé qui a lui aussi qui a pris le
parti du lien qui a dit que c'était une
admissible ce qui s'était passé alors
Mathieu tu es le grand frère de Julien
voilà tu soutiens ton frère à 100% toi
bien sûr déjà je tiens à souligner que
si je suis venu ici c'est parce que je
réponds à une invitation et que c'est
que c'est formidable d'O une tribune à
mon frère en fait qui ne peut pas lui
s'exprimer puisqu'il est exactement au
château là donc je prends la parole pour
lui
qui vient on l'invité on lui a dit voilà
on aimerait avoir ton avis là-dessus
après voilà il va pas faire du buzz
exactement pour faire du boss pour moi
ni pour pour cracher sur TF1 non plus je
n'ai aucune sur personne et on attend
voilà c'est le covid
avec personne je suis marié avec
personne je suis ici parce que j'ai mon
intégrité et que je supporte pas qu'un
gamin de 20 ans mon petit frère puisse
être comme ça pris à partir et par une
prof qui a certes des compétences et qui
est peut-être qu'il a peut-être beaucoup
aidé sur plein de sujets mais en tout
cas là ça pour moi ça va un petit peu
trop loin et heureusement qu'il est
équilibré qu'il a des gens qui
l'entourent une famille moi etc qui qui
lui dise voilà garder les pieds sur
terre et de garder la tronche froide
comme on dit chez moi mais
ça me fait de la peine voilà de le voir
comme ça accabler et je le sens je le
sens peiné il avait envie d'exploser et
je lui ai dit au téléphone quand on
s'est eu au château voilà j'ai eu écoute
les profs voilà reste focus sur ton
aventure mais reste toi-même aussi mais
c'est parce qu'il est comme ça que les
gens le sauve aussi
la sincérité Semino exactement il est
lui-même à 200 pour ça qu'on kiffe moi
j'ai envie d'un mec qui font un peu la
merde aussi il était très populaire
parce qu'il était insupportable
déjà j'ai adoré la séquence parce que je
trouve qu'on retrouve le ses émissions
avec des profs la prof mine
ensuite j'ai vu qu'il y a des gens qui
parlaient d'humiliation je pense qu'à un
moment faut arrêter deux secondes
aujourd'hui plus rien dire on peut plus
pousser quelqu'un c'est retranchement
sans qu'on parle de manipulateur de
harceleur de pervers narcissique c'est
bon les gars c'est un débrief de la star
acade elle fait son job son job se faire
des remarques il faut arrêter et c'est
une très très bonne séquence et c'est ça
qu'on va voir dans la star acade c'est
pas un truc assez petit où il se dit
rien en fait c'est pour ça et c'est pour
ça que je suis là pour avoir comme pour
donner comme une espèce de droit de
réponse à mon frère qui lui a été coupé
quand même montage officiel de l'astacle
c'est ça qui est dommage j'en vois
personne je critique personne aucune
prod ou quoi je m'en fous mais ça me
fait chier voilà
que c'est pour ça aussi que tu avais ça
voilà la fragilité de mon frère elle se
situe en fait
d'une certaine manière c'est celui qui
arrive en dernier dans la famille on est
tous une famille de musiciens et tout et
ça pour créer sa place pour faire sa
place c'est compliqué donc il a un
manque de confiance en Lui total il a
été appelé pour faire la soirée qu'il a
pas postulé il a pas toqué la porte pour
dire voilà j'aimerais j'ai envie de
faire seul aucune prétention là-dedans
et si voilà je débarque ici et malgré
lui en fait et on lui dit qu'il a du
talent il y a il y va doucement il reste
lui-même et autour de candidats qui sont
dans la compète totale et mais voilà
j'en veux aucun candidat aussi chacun
fait son expérience et voilà il faut
être très bien après c'est vrai que tous
les professeurs ils sont un petit peu
sur le dos de Julien chant dans Sport
regardez
bien j'aimerais que tu te taises
j'ai dit de pas parler Julia je
m'écoutes pas parce qu'à chaque fois que
je me tourne vers toi tu es en train de
faire soit autre chose soit en train de
parler à quelqu'un d'autre s'il vous
plaît là Julien tu fais trop de bruit là
oh [ __ ] c'est bon je me casse j'en ai
marre c'est bon stop allez
[ __ ]
bad boy du château lui hein
j'ai envie qu'on me lâche un peu la
grappe moi j'ai entendu parler c'est
normal qu'elle te dise juste et toi ça
sert à rien de quitter le cours en plein
milieu
j'ai envie qu'on me lâche un peu la
grappe une phrase qu'on retiendra
c'est vrai c'est bon merci oui Gilles
non moi je suis pas tellement d'accord
avec Guillaume je trouve que la prof
elle le juge pour ceux qui l'est et pas
pour ce qu'il fait c'est ça qui me gêne
donc je trouve ça un peu violent je
trouve que là le dépasse la mesure voilà
ça fait une bonne séquence mais à quel
prix
va voir la vidéo de Matthieu oui
en revanche
en revanche elle a tort de dire que
c'est qu'on s'en fout du public bien sûr
c'est le public qui fait la carrière
c'est une grosse connerie je vais te
dire Julien il fera une plus grosse
carrière que tous ceux qui seront sauvés
par les professeurs
parce qu'il le trouve tous
extraordinaire il le pousse dans ses
retranchements pour pouvoir encore plus
du sens des mots du moment présent etc
elle a quand même une dimension presque
un peu un peu spirituelle dans ses cours
et tout et c'est cool mais quand on
parle quand on emploie la formule le
sens des mots c'est bien aussi de
l'avoir pour soi-même quel mot tu as
choqué toi moi ce qui m'a choqué en fait
c'est un peu la c'est le temps en fait
qu'elle utilisait avec Julien
regarde-moi ça fait ci comme s'il avait
12 ans je veux dire un moment donné il
faut aussi on regarde son propre si on
arrête pas de dire qu'on regarde plus
les profs aujourd'hui
malgré tout c'est l'autorité
mon frère
elle fait figure d'autorité certes mais
mon frère est aussi un artiste et il
faut il faut qu'il puisse aussi avoir
son mot dire et et c'est le côté voilà
le public on s'en fout ça c'est un truc
je veux dire c'est n'importe quel
artiste je pense que c'est le Béaba
après elle fait le spectacle
et également ce que il y en a qui ont
été choqués par cette séquence juste
quelques il y a que toi il y a que toi
oui ben j'ai été très choqué oui ça m'a
fait mal pour et je trouve que ça
dépasse le cadre normal voilà on est un
petit peu un petit peu à fleur de peau
quand même exactement je suis sensible
aussi et je trouve que pour s'allonge
sur les autoroutes on a rien à [ __ ]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
sur ses yeux et qui viendra nous voir et
ben c'est avec grand plaisir si vous
l'avez déjà
tu dis que j'embrasse fort ok que
vraiment je le trouve formidable et
c'est lui c'est je te dis c'est la star
du programme voilà c'est clair mais il
faut que les profs gardent ce
comportement avec lui c'est ça qui va
leur demander bien sûr exactement
s'il vous plaît si c'est pas trop vous
demander oui il y a 52% non à 49
c'est pas du tout
merci Macron merci ma clé merci merci
monsieur